trois ans après victoria présenté à la
semaine de la critique à cannes virginie
efira revient au pays cette fois en
compétition avec le rôle-titre de
sybille c'est le troisième film de
justin triais est le deuxième que la
comédienne est la réalisatrice tourner
l'ensemble son personnage est une
psychanalyste qui voudraient fermer son
cabinet pour devenir romancière mais
elle est harcelée par une actrice
débutante interprétée par la très juste
adèle exarque aux bulls qui réclame son
aide et qui va l'entraîner sur un
tournage en italie entre comédie
grinçante sur le cinéma et thriller
psychologique sybille est un film en
plein si mieux où les personnages
perdent souvent leurs repères tout le
contraire de sa comédienne qui suit une
route rectiligne et triomphale vers le
succès depuis qu'elle a quitté son
premier métier de télévision bonjour
gergy maintenant merci beaucoup d'être
avec eux ça vous arrive encore de perdre
les repères
oh oui heureusement qu'il est pensent
les maîtriser et fous je crois surtout
ans mais comédienne ce que tout le monde
perd par moments des repères ce que tout
le temps ce qui voudrait les avoir en
permanence quand on est acteur encore
plus
mais penser que les choses sont
immuables c'est déjà un leurre en soi
assez mal grand public tout en gardant
quand même un pied dans le grand bain
jean leloup je vous avais peu à peu
glissé vers le cinéma d'auteur
je pense à caprice d'emmanuel mouret à
elle de paul verhoeven et puis surtout
victoria de justin trier suivi d'un
amour impossible de catherine corsini
qu'est ce que vous allez chercher vos
précisément en tant que comédienne dans
ce cinéma plus indépendants bas des gens
avec qui j'ai envie de parler des gens
qui m'intéresse c'est d'abord au fait
aussi une question de rapports moi j'ai
aimé le cinéma comme spectatrice pour
avoir le sentiment ou l'illusion d'être
moins seul
et bien c'est ce qu'on a envie de
ressentir de manière presque plus
concrète aussi prouvé - seul devant le
cinéma indépendant bastad et rothko tout
cas par exemple justin c'est très fort
c'est quelqu'un avec qui je partage une
intimité à tous points de vue
enfin tout point de vue à ce qu'elle
prétend
on ne sait jamais de quoi décrit situer
ce que la vie nous réserve mais mais
voilà bien un endroit de compréhension
mutuelle et tout ça il ya c'est pas
nouveau ce que ça veut dire cinéma
d'auteur mais donc ça veut dire qu'il
serait un peu plus un peu plus
débarrasser des contingents strictement
financière ce qui fait qu'il pourrait y
avoir une liberté de geste artistique
peut-être plus forte volonté se sont
payés le conditionnel mais vous le
sentez parfois oui c'est à dire que tu
coup tu peux avoir accès mais c'est un
repas parfois un peu moins cadenassé où
l'idée qu'un personnage qu'on devrait
suivre forcément sympathique
or n'aurait que des bonnes actions un
passeport de moralité peut-être aussi
par rapport au rôle peut-être
qu'effectivement cancan quand j'ai fait
des comédies romantiques dont je trouve
certaines vraiment bien il y avait
malgré tout peut-être une somme des tic
est un personnage un peu plus prototype
à l'on va dire ou home était plus en
avant une douceur une compréhension une
indépendance en même temps fait des
choses comme un petit package qu'il est
intéressant de détruire un ont fait un
truc dingue la toux et demain les
fouilles d'accord on regarde une scène
de civils ok alors pas n'importe qu'elle
cède en l'occurrence c'est la première
la première où vous apparaissez est la
première qui en réalité est un long plan
fixe qui dit presque tout de la vie de
votre personnage
on est parti c'est le mécanisme de base
de la lecture c'est quand même deux lors
de la prise d'otages tu va imposer à
quelqu'un de passer 4 5 6 7 8 heures
dans ton cerveau et donc là c'est
effectivement la première scène du film
avec aurélien bélanger qui est un grand
ami de justin et qui est un grand auteur
et l'idée là c'est la somme
d'informations dont il l'a saoulée
d'ailleurs ça serait présente aussi sur
tous ces petits plats japonais qui passe
devant au on sait que choisir c'est ça
représente espèce de chaos
invraisemblable de somme d'informations
elle elle veut écrire et lui c'est son
éditeur et lui explique bon que tout est
très compliqué on rencontre tous dans le
vit un moment quelqu'un qui te
décourages de faire quelque chose que tu
aurais envie de faire et en même temps
il dit des choses assez justes il dit
que pour créer quelque chose ou pour
écrire quelque chose s'est pas achevé
d'écrire sur tel sujet c'est
souvent une somme de différentes
influences de choses qu'on va prendre
dans la vie de quelqu'un de choses
auxquelles qui est une résidence
personnelle ou un film qu'on a vu voilà
qu'il ya dans le geste de création d'une
multitude de choses qui se mettent en
place en trois heures et à la fin il y
aura rien il y aura rien parce qu'ils
pensent qu'ils ont une idée ils pensent
ils ont quelque chose à dire
alors qu'en fait non la fiction c'est
pas sérieux que lui qui parle et moi je
suis assommé par par ce flux tendu de
parole justine elle vous guident son
rôle elle vous dit quoi
non moi j'écoute juste un bon je ne dis
pas que c'est rien d'écouter ses mais
aurélien il a aussi un truc fou de nous
parle un peu comme ça elle et elle est
très particulier quoi d intelligence
absolument remarquable et tout ça et
donc il peut improviser sur des choses
ça me fait penser aussi une scène de
victoria pour ceux qui s'en souviennent
c'est marrant pourrait croire quand le
film commence que ça va être une sorte
de victoria 2 parce qu'elle est
exactement cette scène là dans un
mariage je voudrais me concentrer sur
quelque chose et aurélien me parle de
trucs de physique quantique mélanger
achètent pas tous quoi et ça n'en finit
jamais on ne sait pas comment arrêter la
conversation
j'aime bien que ça démarre sur quelque
chose qui ces dépenses est déjà aux
films précédents et après on va s'en
défaire terriblement fort parce que je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais ce
qui est assez remarquable pour moi c'est
comment justin d'un film à l'autre
transforme change va voir ailleurs il va
peut-être même voir plus loin et en même
temps il ya une vraie continuité et
c'est ça qui est assez passionnant et
l'aquagym et elle passe par vous
également un certain moment je me suis
même demandé si justin trier ne s'était
pas imprégnés de tous vos rôles de
cinéma pour construire celui là qui
touche au métier de comédienne
non parce que c'est pas comme si elle
était tombée sur 2,9 ou marion cotillard
qui avaient déjà une soeur de
filmographie qui a tourné avec quand
j'ai fait victoria ce qui était assez
chouette c'est que je pense pas qu'elle
a vue forcément beaucoup de films mais
ce qui était super c'est que même en
faisant tout d'un coup effectivement un
film avec une économie différente avec
des bizarreries ça restait malgré tout
une comédie romantique et c'est assez
amusant d'utiliser quelqu'un qui avait
déjà fait ce genre de choses mais à des
endroits beaucoup plus tordus ça je
trouvais chouette mais c'est plus
histoire que moi je me suis raconter
plus quelle joie sybille c'est un film
de cinéphiles aussi une grande partie se
déroule sur l'île de stromboli comme le
film de roberto rossellini avec ingrid
bergman votre rôle auprès d' adèle
exarque route rappelle le psychanalyste
et mentor que marilyn monroe emmené avec
elle sur les tournages ou pense aussi à
la nuit américaine de truffaut qui
raconte le tournage d'un film et ce
qu'elle voulait demander justin trier de
voir des films pour préparer ce
personnage est un film de woody allen
avec gêna rowlands mondiale elle est
présent dans le film
oui je reprise bas notamment la scène où
vous chevauchez gaspard ulliel qui est
pratiquement une citation de match folle
qu'est le chevauche ouais voilà je suis
en plein déni et donc sur ce film de
woody allen elle vous dit quoi
ben là c'était une première chose
c'était c'était l'idée qu'une femme
espionne une autre femme en pleine
séance de psychanalyse là dans le film
de woody allen lcc par un conduit
d'aération elle est dans un appartement
elle veut écrire et puis par le conduit
d'aération on entend une voix et en fait
c'est le bureau du psychanalyste en bas
et du coup c'est par cette voie là
qu'elle va entendre que quelque chose en
elle qui coup ça va réveiller quelque
chose en elles et un basculement et ça
c'est un point d'origine après moi
j'aime on partage beaucoup de films elle
et moi parfois quand je vois des choses
qui me font penser à justin je montrais
et bien sûr dans l'autre cas par rapport
au travail j'ai pas beaucoup sauf s'il
ya eu beaucoup de choses si sur les
scènes de sexe énormément de choses
qu'on a regardé
du paul verhoven d'ailleurs aussi et et
puis aussi parce que dans le film il ya
de l'alcool et elles tombent elles
chutent pas l'idée du corps et tout ça
est bon on en revient toujours à general
ans mais effectivement sur le corps
solide qui s'effondre qu'est ce que
c'est que chuter comme on tombe
c'était assez présent aussi une fois ce
que j'adore dans le film bien gira c'est
quand la réalisatrice du film qui est
tournée qui est interprétée par
l'actrice allemande sandra ulla inquiet
dit la grande fête d'origine quand même
hurlé à son plateau folie collective
garder le drama pour la fiction vous sur
un plateau de tournage
vous gardez le drama pour la fiction
ouais j'aime bien j'aime bien lüthi et
je viens même utiliser des choses de la
vie pour après la guerre j'étais dans la
fiction à quitter carrément s'engueuler
avec quelqu'un que vous aimez ou avec
keenan sur le tournage ça m'arrive pas
souvent de me disputer avec quelqu'un je
n'ai pas envie de citer qui mais il
s'était passé ça un endroit et je sais
que du coup ça c'est moi il ya eu un
petit et fusion j'ai dit ok on tourne là
maintenant comme si j'étais metteur en
scène tout à coup en faire quelque chose
quelque part parce que la scène
nécessité ça donc peut-être que ça va
animer chez nous des endroits un peu
plus est quand même une sorte de mise à
nu enfin faut pas exagérer mais comme m
quand il contient quand il ya des scènes
avec un état particulier c'est sûr que
l'on n'a pas
la porosité plus forte on n'a pas la
même carapace et c est peut-être que de
fait de devoir jouer ça nous avait mis
un peu plus à vif
et puis bon là utilisé oui catherine
corsini que j'ai interviewé un joint
ailleurs m'a dit de vous que vous étiez
humble que votre spécificité
je fais bien semblant de la vigueur à
ses vrais jeux rigolos des focales de
dire par là non mais non mais je sais
pas moi
il ya deux choses que celle qui m'évoque
ça c'est josiane d'une émission j'étais
invité ou y avait que des belges et tout
ça et on parlait entre nous de la
modestie à la modestie belge et tout et
on se vantait nos propres modestie là je
me suis dit qu'il y avait un problème
déjà
ensuite tout seul tu es pas grand-chose
de pertes est rien il n'y a pas de là
dedans une chose que pratiquent parfois
quelques acteurs et que j'arrive à
comprendre sur une détestation de leur
emploi de leur métier je le voyais un
documentaire sur un dd des très grands
acteurs américains qui parfois ce qui
sont spectaculaires et qui qui détestent
leur travail qui se trouve c'est un
travail et il n'y a pas du tout ça chez
moi je trouve que c'est un travail
absolument merveilleux mais en même
temps peut pas non plus un seul on est
vraiment rien quoi c'est difficile de
s'extraire du monde du cinéma
je vous pose la question parce que le
film parle de ça aussi si si c'est
difficile de rester difficile en tout
cas déjà dit j'ai dû dire entrer un je
connais mieux ce sens là ces deux-ci
extraire ben pas moi j'ai pas trop envie
pour le moment je vais rester encore un
peu gêné aux veaux verra peut-être
l'année prochaine à cannes avec le
nouveau film de paul verhoeven benedetta
vous incarnez une religieuse lesbiennes
vos personnages sont de plus en plus
transgressifs devrait passer de vingt
ans d'écart à la nonne homosexuels
virgile oui ça c'est quelque chose comme
ça tant mieux je pense que si je jouais
en permanence des choses
extrêmement alambiqué j'aurais peut-être
un grand désir de normalité je voudrais
mais là oui c'est c'est justement dans
cette idée de voyage en soi ces
possibilités infinies de voyage en soi
et d'arpenter des choses différentes on
n'a pas envie d'être d'être forcément
sur le même registre tout le temps ou
pas les fouilles à des endroits un peu
plus
voilà on a beaucoup parlé de la zone
grise elle m'intéresse trois nominations
aux césar en deux avec une place assez
importante quand même dans le cinéma
français où propose des films de partie
de ces rares comédienne qui sont comme
ozzy bankable c'est ça la suite c'est
quoi c'est aussi produire des films ce
site plus s'impliquer pour vous en tant
que nouveau le succès c'est une chose
qui est quelqu'un peut relativiser tout
ça
la seule manière concrète dans tout ce
que vous avez dit da de le ressentir
c'est sur la proposition de rôle et ça
c'est grâce à justin c'est à dire grâce
à victoria assez skalli a changé sur les
propositions de rôles oui sur avant de
proposer des choses mais là ça élargit
sur des genres de films très différents
des gens de personnages très différents
très clairement sur le reste c'est
toujours plus au moment où tu tourne un
film c'est là que tu es en train de
faire quelque chose le reste quelque
part ne t'appartient pas tu ne peux rien
changer non qui tu te défonces a prôné
me pouvoir réaliser produire par exemple
ça vous le feriez j'ai dans l'idée par
exemple j'adorerais tu sais écrire
réaliser un film et j'ai cette espèce de
complexe je me dis si vraiment je
l'écriture était au centre de moi ça
ferait longtemps que j'ai que j'écrirais
que j'ai tu vois et que je joue et que
je saurais parler français aussi ça
serait bien exactement la même
non mais je vous dirais que comme je ne
le fais pas là je me dis donc je veux
peut-être que je réalisera un film à 65
ans mais ce serait tout de suite la nuit
du chasseur et produire et comme vous
voulez les actrices américaines ont
parfois même très abîmé le cinéma n'est
pas tout à fait de même alors
effectivement après victoria j'ai une
crise d'immobilité c'est à dire c'était
tellement quelque chose de faire ce film
avec justin c'était tellement une autre
approche dans le travail tout ça que je
pouvais pas tout de suite me remettre à
travailler ou à accepter les mêmes
choses qu'avant
et alors quand les gens disent qu'est ce
que tu faisais fait en ce moment et que
je faisais j'attends j'avais une honte
j'attends je tente légende le désir est
ce que c'est on attend beaucoup de nous
non en fait non
sur le plateau de tournage de temps à
oui bah du coup qui le désiraient
puisque mahé désir le désir c'est de la
tempe de désir
oui mais bon c'est vrai que c'est des
idées que j'aime bien tordre un peu
aussi mentalement quand même mais bon
comme l'idée juste d'attendre me
semblait un tout petit peu soit trop
paresseuse soit en tout cas trop
ennuyeuse
g j'ai pensé avec une amie qui est
critique littéraire qui savait
clémentine bolzan a à dire tiens on
partirait de livres qu'on dirait
proposer des metteurs en scène
voila voila et je les fais avec très peu
de 2,2
enfin devenir le film est pas éclatante
réussite mais qui s'appelle continuer de
joachim lafosse
mais qui d'un livre vraiment c'est des
mains de laurent mauvignier et donc oui
où j'ai fini je n'ai pas du tout produit
mais c'est vrai que c'était que c'était
une envie qu'on avait de voir ça au
cinéma mais ensuite et heureusement
d'ailleurs
et c'était le cas sur le sur ce film là
c'est un metteur en scène après qui doit
décider moi je pourrai jamais allé voir
l'inter en scène en disant j'ai envie de
travailler avec vous c'est quand même
toujours quelque chose qui se passe dans
les deux sens mais si tu arrive avec une
idée une envie de quelque chose en
disant - la mettre en scène je ne sais
pas mais est-ce que vous ça vous
intéresse
en fait c'est là ça peut être c'est une
démarche que je trouve qui peut être
quand même intéressante et porteuse oui
mais mais après il faut malgré tout ça
va donner un regard donc c'est pas
diriger quelque chose merci infiniment
n'a rien offert à sybille de justin
trieste est à voir en salles le 24 mai
le même jour que sa présentation au
compétition au festival
virginie efira il est entouré dada
l'exarque claude gaspard ulliel l'heure
quels amis ni le gender on espère très
fort retrouvez ce film au palmarès ce
samedi